JeanLouis très beau cadeau
voilà c'est fini on attend ressasser les
mêmes théories on a tellement tiré
chacun de notre
côté que
voilà c'est fini trouve un autrerocher
petit htre perlé
ne laisse pas trop couler de temps sous
tontiné allez Thierry car c'est
[Musique]
fini c'est
fini
voilà c'est fini on va pas se dire au
revoir comme sur le quai d'une gare je
dis seulement bonjour et fais gaffe à
l'amour
voilà c'est fini aujourd'hui ou demain
c'est le moment où tuaimis peut-être
après-demain tu nous
retrouveras car c'est
fini c'est
[Musique]
fini tu as fini par te dire qu'on
éviterait le
pire qu'il fallait mieux couper plutôt
que
déchirer tu as fini par te dire que
peut-être on va
grandir
et que même si c'est non et que même si
c'est
con tous les deux nous
savons que de toute
façon
voilà c'est fini ne sois jamais amère
reste toujours sincère tu as eu ce que
tu as voulu même si tu as pas voulu ce
que tu as
eu
voilà c'est fini le demain se desserr de
s'être trop serré la foule nous emporte
chacun de notre
côté car c'est
fini c'est
fini allez à l'année
prochaine merci
[Applaudissements]
tu es tu
es
[Applaudissements]
de